SRINI DEVADAS:
Let's get started.
So today, we're going to look
at one of my favorite puzzles.
I'll say right at the beginning,
that the coding associated
with the puzzle is
fairly straightforward.
But the analysis associated with
this puzzle is quite intricate.
And in particular,
we're going to have
to do worst-case analysis, which
is really a good thing for you
to learn about, because
asymptotic analysis
in algorithms is all
about worst case.
All right.
So keep that in mind.
When you try to come up with
the answers to my questions,
always keep in
mind that I'm going
to be asking for what
happens in the worst case.
In the context of our puzzle--
which is called the
crystal ball puzzle,
and it's fairly
popular in literature,
though I've generalized
it a little bit--
you have a situation
where you're
supposed to figure out
the hardness coefficient
of a crystal ball.
And in the generalized
version, you
have a set of identical
crystal balls.
So how do you find this
hardness coefficient?
Well, you go up to the Shanghai
Tower that has 128 floors--
1 through 128-- and you drop
this ball from say, floor 1.
So just you're standing
here and let's say,
you just drop it from there.
Or you go up to floor 2,
and you drop the ball.
And the hardness
coefficient is defined
as the highest floor from
which you can drop the ball
and the ball does not break.
So what this means
is if at floor f,
the ball doesn't break,
and it breaks at f plus 1,
then the hardness
coefficient is f.
And you can assume a
monotonicity property
that says that if it did
not break at floor f, then
it won't break--
this implies that it won't
break at any floor less than
or equal to f.
Which makes sense, right?
And otherwise, it would
be kind of complicated.
It would be random.
And we won't be able to do
any interesting analysis.
So the easy version
of the puzzle,
of course, which is not
particularly interesting,
is if you needed to
get this exactly--
so your job depends on getting
that number exactly right--
so there's no shortcuts.
You've got to get it right.
You can't be off
by one either way.
And you have only one ball.
So you only have one ball.
So what can you do if
you only have one ball
and you have to get
it exactly right?
AUDIENCE: Just try every floor.
SRINI DEVADAS: Try every floor.
Right.
And but more important,
try it from lower floors
to higher floors, right?
So you drop it at floor 1.
So one ball, you
drop from floor 1.
And if it breaks, then
your hardness coefficient
is, you return 0.
But then if you keep going and
let's say, you drop off dot,
dot, dot--
of from floor 65 and it breaks,
and you've gone in order,
then the hardness
coefficient is 64.
So that's easy enough.
There's no optimization here.
It's the only thing you can do.
So that's why it's not
particularly interesting.
Now if you have identical
crystal balls that
are guaranteed, they
were manufactured
in exactly the same way,
et cetera, et cetera, then
obviously, things get
a lot more interesting,
because you can try
to minimize something.
And I'm going to
write it over here,
because I want you to keep this
in mind throughout the lecture.
Our goal here is to minimize
the worst-case number
of drops for our problem.
And we want to solve the
problem in the general case
with d balls.
And I should say,
d identical balls.
But more important, the
reason I'm writing this up
is, as I said before, we need
to focus on the worst case.
So it may be the case that
for a given set of balls,
your algorithm does very well,
in the sense that the hardness
coefficient happened to be 42.
And you picked the floor
as of 41 to begin with.
And so you dropped from
41, and it doesn't break.
And then you go to 42,
and it doesn't break.
And you go to 43, and it breaks.
And you go, oh, I
only needed two drops
for this particular problem.
But if the hardness
coefficient happened to be 65
and you started from
floor 41, I mean
you'd need 20-odd
number of drops.
So you have to be
careful in that you
have to analyze whatever
strategy you come up
with in the case where the
hardness coefficient could
be pretty much anything.
I mean it could be 0 or it could
be 128 in our Shanghai Tower
example.
So the first
interesting question
is, what happens when I
have two identical balls?
So, oh, before we
do that, according
to my metric here, what is
the worst-case number of drops
for one ball?
What is the worst-case
number of drops for one ball?
Give me a number.
Someone else.
Yeah, back there.
AUDIENCE: 128.
SRINI DEVADAS:
128, exactly right.
So it's 128,
because I could have
had a ball that doesn't
break from the 128 floor.
I don't know that to begin with.
I have to start with floor 1.
And I got to go 1, 2,
3, 4, et cetera, right?
So the worst case
for one ball is 128.
And you can't do
better than that.
But of course, it gets more
interesting when d is large.
So our goal now is to
discover an algorithm that
is going to minimize the
worst-case number of drops
for d equals 2.
That's our current goal, right?
And then we'll look at more,
even more general things.
So how would you do things
if you had d equals 2?
Just, it doesn't matter if you
don't get our algorithm right.
We'll analyze it.
You propose something.
And then we'll decide if
we can do better or not.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Drop the ball from
the halfway point, say 64.
If it breaks there, then
you can use the bottom half
of what we are using.
SRINI DEVADAS: Use
the bottom half.
Excellent.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Dhaman.
SRINI DEVADAS: Sorry.
SRINI DEVADAS: Dhaman.
So Dhaman says that we should
do binary search, which
is very intuitive and
kind of makes sense
in a lot of context,
including this one.
And so let's drop from 64.
And the reason she picked that
is because 128 divided by 2
is 64.
And if it breaks, then you need
to look at the interval, 1, 63
because if it--
I'm sorry.
Yeah, that's right.
If it breaks, you need to
look at the interval 1, 63
with a second ball.
I mean that first ball is gone.
It's shards of crystal or
whatever you want to call it.
So you just have
the second ball.
And so now at this point,
you have no choice.
You only have one ball left.
As I mentioned, your
job depends on getting
that hardness coefficient
right, so you can only
use that first algorithm
in terms of starting from 1
and going all the way to 63.
And so what is the
worst-case number
of drops given that
Dhaman picked the midpoint
for this algorithm?
Someone else.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It's 63.
SRINI DEVADAS: It's 63.
No actually, you're off by 1.
Because I did drop the
ball here, so close.
So the first ball was
dropped once, one drop.
And this one, if in fact, the
hardness coefficient was 64,
you drop the second
ball 63 times.
And that would be the worst
case in this instance.
Now, I've skipped
over one little thing.
The fact that this
is the midpoint
implies that this is, in
fact, the correct answer.
But we do have to analyze.
I mean remember, you know,
when you do analysis,
you do have to cover the
entire spectrum here.
So you do have to look at the
case where the drop from 64
does not break.
And in that case, you're
looking at 65 through 128.
But you do have
two balls for this.
It didn't break.
So you still have
two balls for that.
And so you can imagine that,
now that you have two balls
and you have a small
interval, that you're
going to be able to do
something like 32 for that.
The bottom line is,
you don't even need to.
You can get a little
bit lazy here.
You don't really need to
analyze what the number is,
because you know that
this number, 63 plus 1,
is larger than that--
because you wanted
worst case, right?
So this is the kind
of thing that you'll
have to do when you do
algorithmic analysis.
Maybe not exactly in a
puzzle situation like this,
but you have to look
at all the cases.
And you have to find kind
of the max of all the cases.
So is this the best you can do?
Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You could break the
128 into smaller sections using
the first ball.
So instead of
breaking it in half,
you could do it every 16 floors.
SRINI DEVADAS: Every 16 floors.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Starting
from the bottom,
and then once the
first ball breaks,
then you have a smaller interval
to test with the second ball.
So let's say it
breaks at the 32nd.
Then you have to only test for
16 to 32, instead of 1 to 32.
SRINI DEVADAS: That's correct.
Yeah.
So it shows how you can do it--
I mean, this is,
obviously there's not
going to be a whole
lot of optimization
here with d equals 2.
But you'd be surprised
as to how much better you
can do than 64, which
is obviously a big step
forward from 128.
But you can go a few
more steps as well.
And so what was your name?
AUDIENCE: Lucy.
SRINI DEVADAS: Lucy.
So Lucy has it right.
It's a similar idea, except
you don't necessarily
need to do the
intuitive binary search.
It's actually kind of different
from that because of the way
this problem is structured.
And what her idea is is
that we'll look at something
smaller, a smaller interval.
And she picked 16, so let's
go 16, 32 is our algorithm.
It's something that goes 16,
32, 48, 64, dot, dot, dot.
And maybe gets up all the way
to I guess, yeah 128 and 16.
So 128 is a multiple
of 16, right?
Some math person
make sure I'm right.
So what happens here?
So let's analyze
this to make sure
that we're good in
terms of an improvement.
We have to be careful.
So let's just
arbitrarily say that it
broke at 64, because that's
kind of what happened over
in that previous algorithm too.
So that means I've done
four drops without a break.
I'm sorry, four drops.
Three drops without a
break and four drops total.
So I've done four drops.
But now the cool thing is I
don't have to start from 16.
I know it didn't break at 48.
So I can now look at four
drops till break of first ball.
That is what I wanted to say.
And now, I can look
at the interval 49.
Because 48, it did not break--
49 to 63, inclusive.
And so if you do
that, that's 15.
It's 15.
The difference is 14, but
it's inclusive, so it's 15.
So 15 plus 4, that is 19 drops.
Yeah.
Back there.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
the worst case
though be when it's at 127.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yes,
that's absolutely correct.
So 19 is not the worst case.
I mean it's looking good,
but this was exactly
the point I was trying to
make right from the beginning.
You are not done yet.
I mean, you cannot just go off
and say that 19 is the worst
case for this algorithm.
The worst case for
this algorithm--
this particular algorithm
occurs at a different point
from the original
algorithm that went midway.
Every algorithm is different.
The parameters are
different here.
And so I'm just calling
a different algorithm.
But the case that
would happen is
I guess you would have 112 here.
And then you'd go
1, 2, so how many?
So let's say it gets to 128.
And if it doesn't break,
then you're clearly done.
So that's not the worst case.
So if it gets to 128 and it
breaks, then so how many drops
have we done?
128 divided 16 is what?
Is 8.
Are you sure?
You're all sure?
OK.
Then I'm sure.
So that's eight drops.
And now you need
to do 113 to 127.
And that we know is 15.
So that's 23.
All right.
So the best you have
done here is 23.
But are we satisfied?
We're never satisfied.
We always want to do
a little bit better.
So how did she pick 16?
Why did you come
up with 16, Lucy?
It looked like a nice number?
AUDIENCE: I just
figured it divides 128.
SRINI DEVADAS: You
just figured, oh, nice.
So if you'd had 17, then we
would have had real trouble
with all these numbers.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
Josh.
AUDIENCE: Think you can
do a little bit better
if you get closer to
the square root of 128?
SRINI DEVADAS: Ah,
beautiful, beautiful.
I love you guys.
You guys make it so easy.
So that's the next
thing I was going
to try and pry out of
you, but you got it out
without much effort from me.
So you can kind of get
analytical here as opposed
to doing things empirically,
which was try a number
and figure out what happened,
which is kind of what we did.
And you can be a little
more analytical about this
and you could say,
hey, suppose I
want to find this number k,
which is kind of the 64--
started with 64, went to 16.
And now, we're thinking we
can do better than 16 even.
And we start dropping
things at k, 2k, 3k.
And I want to get
this exactly right.
So let me look at my notes.
And you go dot, dot, dot--
n divided by k minus 1 times
k and n divided by k times
k, which is obviously m.
And so I'm trying to,
I'm trying to write it--
I'm trying to get this k.
I want to write something.
I want to minimize
at some quantity
and discover the k that is
going to give me my best
case in the worst case--
minimize the worst case, right?
So that's really what I want.
So if you look at
what happens here,
you're in a situation
where you have to now,
you have a count, right?
I mean, well, what
do you want to--
we've decided that k is
this general strategy.
And we don't quite
know what k is.
And we have to do some analysis
of the worst-case situation
in order to find the k that
would work well for us.
And so the way you do this is
by, essentially, the analysis
we've done so far.
And kind of we have a nice,
the point that was made here,
I think, it was Kevin who said
we have to go to the last drop,
because that's kind of the
case where it's the worst case.
And that's similar here as well.
Because if you go
up all the way here
and then it breaks, if
it doesn't break here,
you're done.
If it breaks here, then you've
got, you've done a lot of drops
before it broke that first ball.
And so that's the situation
which you can pull in
as your worst-case situation.
So that's exactly
what we did before.
And so if you really
think about it,
assume first ball doesn't
break until the last drop is
the worst-case situation.
And so what does that mean
from a symbolic standpoint
of with respect to the
number of drops of--
so the number of drops in
this case of the first ball?
Can someone give me
an equation for it?
Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: n over k.
SRINI DEVADAS: n over k.
You a Kevin too?
Yeah.
OK.
So n over k.
Right.
So that's what happened there.
Now, well, it broke, right?
That's what we decided here.
And so now, you need to
search n k plus 1 to--
well, you got to go
all the way there.
I'm sorry, it broke there,
so you got to go n minus 1.
This is the same as
what I wrote before,
but it's just that
I had numbers.
And it was kind of
easier to write numbers
than write these symbols.
But we have to do this because
we don't know what k is.
So if you look at
how many drops are--
and if you're just going
to do this, you get--
if you notice, this
gets simplified to n.
Yeah, so this is n,
and then you have
minus k plus 1, all
the way to n minus 1.
So if you subtract, and
this is a plus 1 here.
Boy, this is confusing.
I'm not good at math.
I'm definitely not good at math.
So this is k minus 1
drops in the worst case.
All right.
So you now need to add
these two things together.
So what we'd like to do
is minimize n divide it
by k, which is this plus that.
We want to minimize
this function.
And it's a constant.
k is a variable.
And for a given n, we want
to discover the k that
minimizes this quantity.
And it goes back
to the intuition
that I think Josh had
about the square root of n.
So again, high school calculus
here, which I've forgotten,
which hopefully you haven't
because you still need it.
I don't.
And you end up
essentially saying
you can turn this
into two raised
to the square root of n minus
1 drops in the worst case.
All right.
So you can take the floor
of that, and that's 11.
So that's that square root of n.
So 2 times 11 minus 1 is 21.
So you can do 21.
So you think 21 is the optimum?
Yeah, Kevin.
AUDIENCE: Can we
do a little better
if we make it go smaller?
SRINI DEVADAS: Yes.
You can do a little bit better.
I don't want to
do this just yet.
Hopefully.
We'll have time.
We'll get to that because I want
to go to the d greater than 2
case, but you're
absolutely right.
It turns out that you can
do, this would give you 21,
as I mentioned, 22 minus 1.
It turns out, you can do
better but by a few drops.
And the assumption we made here,
what is the assumption that we
made here?
When I wrote this, what
assumption did I make,
which is kind of similar
to what Kevin just said,
but not exactly?
Would someone point out the
assumption that was made here?
Not you.
Someone else.
All right.
Ganatra.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: The
intervals are the same.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah.
The intervals are equal.
So this, look, it's
a different problem.
If it didn't break here,
then I got a smaller--
I have two balls.
And I had a smaller problem.
So why would I use the same k?
I mean, that kind of
makes sense, right?
So now, it's more complicated
and hopefully, we'll
get to that.
But I want to do
other things first.
So that's the reason.
So at least you know why
21 isn't optimal, right?
It's because of this constraint
that we placed on ourselves
in order to do this
analysis to get to the point
where we had 2 times square root
of n minus 1 that corresponds
to the equal
interval constraint.
So good.
All right.
Any questions about this?
So as you can
imagine, I'm not going
to show you code that computes 2
times square root of n minus 1.
So that doesn't
make sense, but we
do have code to look at
that corresponds to the case
where d could be
3, d could be 4.
And then obviously, it gets
more interesting in terms
of what your strategy is.
And we won't go with optimizing.
In fact, there's an open problem
as to what the optimum strategy
would be for arbitrary d--
d meaning the number of balls--
if it's 5, 6, whatever--
partly because of what I just
talked about with respect
to you need to utilize
unequal intervals.
But the natural
thing to do now is
to move to d equals a
arbitrary number of balls
and stick with kind of the same
algorithmic approach of having
equal intervals.
But the question is,
what are these intervals?
What and how would we find
the size of these intervals?
Because it's kind of
not immediately obvious
if I told you d was 5.
And you don't want to just
keep the three balls away,
and sell them later, and
just use the two, right?
That doesn't give
you your minimum.
It doesn't minimize
your worst case.
You want to use these balls.
Cool.
All right.
So let's talk a little bit
about if I had d equals 3,
I mean again, you can
use your intuition.
What do you think we should do?
What happened for d equals 2
with respect to that interval
and how is it related to n?
So what do you think, just
wild guess, maybe even?
What do you think
we need to do if we
had d equals 3 for that
very first ball in terms
of what we need to look at in
relation to the interval size?
Yeah.
Back there.
AUDIENCE: We need
a cube root of 128.
SRINI DEVADAS: Ah,
cube root, cube root.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Ryan.
SRINI DEVADAS: Ryan.
So Ryan says, you
know, cube root.
And yeah, that's the
correct intuition.
It's a little bit unclear,
you know, what happens.
You know, so you do cube
roots, and maybe you
have what's the
cube root of 128?
5, yeah, that's right.
I think it's 5.
OK.
It's close to 5, you know.
It's 6 or 5 or 6, right?
And so maybe I do
6, and then I do 12.
And it's a little bit strange.
So it turns out, it's
actually the 6 and 12,
and you start with 128
when you have three balls,
doesn't seem like it's going to
give you the worst case, right?
Because, you know,
like in the worst case,
you might be dropping
the ball 6, 12, 18,
24, et cetera, et cetera.
So cube root is right, but
it's something a little bit
different, because it
gave us this interval that
was kind of too small.
So how would I get
something that's bigger?
You'd want things that
are a little bit bigger.
I mean, I think you're going
in the right direction,
but I don't want
6 and 12 and 18.
I mean, clearly, that's going
to give me like 25 drops
and that's even worse than the
two ball case, which really
means you should lose your
job and never get another one,
right?
So if you do something
that bad, right?
So that's-- what would you do
that's kind of different from
cube root, but
related to cube root?
Yeah, go ahead Fadi.
AUDIENCE: 128
raised to 2/3 maybe?
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah, yeah.
Two thirds.
Exactly right.
So what you want to do
is, you want to start--
it makes sense that when
you have lots of balls,
in terms of being
able to use them,
that you start with larger
intervals and you shrink them.
That's exactly what
happened with two balls.
You started with k in the
case where we had two balls.
And then we are down to
one when we have one ball.
So that's really
what you're doing.
When you have one
ball, all you can do
is go one floor at a time.
When you have two
balls, you go k,
where k happened to
be square root of n.
And then we had three
balls, you kind of
want to start with
like n raised to 2/3
in terms of the interval.
And then if I had four
balls, the argument
would be that I would
start with n raised to 3/4.
And then I would go
to square root of n.
so on and so forth.
And what is that
reminding you of?
What is this, in
terms of these powers
and getting up to not quite
n, but 5, 6th n, so on.
What does that remind
you of from number theory
or just sort of
regular arithmetic?
AUDIENCE: Bases.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah,
different bases.
It's different radix
arithmetic, right?
So it turns out, the way you
want to solve this problem--
and this is in keeping
with the intuition you
have with respect to the cube
roots, and so on, and so forth.
The way we want to
do this is, we want
to think about d digit numbers.
And the numbers themselves,
and d is the number of balls.
And so that's the d digits.
But what is the radix
of these numbers?
The radix of these numbers are
going to be related to the k,
to the intervals.
So you essentially
want to say, you know,
I'm counting in multiples of k--
1k, 2k, 3k, et cetera.
So if I had like
radix k, that means
I'm just incrementing
that particular digit.
You know, if I go,
if I had radix 12,
and I had 1 0 in radix
12, then this would be--
so when I go 2 0, then
the most significant digit
got incremented.
And so this is plus 12.
This is 12 times larger--
I'm sorry-- 12 larger than
two 0's, 12 larger than 1 0
in radix 12.
Make sense?
Just like 20 is 10 larger
than 10 in decimal.
So that's the way you
want to think about this.
And so you're going
to do r-ary numbers.
And the first
thing that you need
to do is, you need
to figure out,
based on the number of floors
that you have, figure out,
you've given d.
You're given n, the
number of floors.
And you're given
the number of balls.
And you got to figure out
what radix you're working in.
And this is going to
be a generalization
of the square root
of n, as you'll see.
We want to choose
a radix such that r
raised to d is greater than n.
Choose r such that r raised
to d is greater than n.
And so that comes
back to, obviously,
if you needed, if d were
2, then it makes sense
that r would be
square root of n,
which is in keeping with
what we talked about.
But if d is 3, then that radix--
not necessarily the
interval that we choose,
because the intervals are
going to be different--
is going to be more
like the cube root of n,
which is also proposed.
Ryan mentioned that.
And so in this case, let's say
that n were 128 and d equals 4.
Then we would choose r equals
4, because 4 raised to 4
is 256, which is
greater than 128.
And we can't choose 3, because
3 raised to 4 is only 81.
And 81 isn't greater than 128.
So you'd have to choose 4.
So what we're now saying is,
we want to somehow figure out--
we're not quite there
in an algorithm yet.
But we have a kind
of a path forward
in that we want to look
at that representation,
that r-ary representation
of these d digit numbers.
And we're going to
essentially increment.
And so with our goal,
roughly speaking,
we're going to go with
this representation.
And we're going to start
incrementing digits.
So we just go 0, 1, 2
in terms of the digits.
But because the
representation is r-ary
that means something
different in terms
of the number of floors,
depending on what r is.
I mean, just like
I said, if we're
this were ternary representation
then in terms of floors,
this is only--
this would be, for ternary,
this would be three floors.
2 0 would be three
floors away from 1 0.
In decimal, 2 0 is 10
floors away from 1 0,
and so on, and so forth.
That makes sense?
Yep.
Ask me questions
if you're confused.
So let's take an example.
So and then we'll look at
code that actually builds
this algorithm from scratch.
So we'll take our
example of d equals
4 for our canonical 128
floor Shanghai Tower,
because you do want to get a
sense of how things improve.
We did improve from
obviously d equals 1
through d equals 2 with the
equal interval assumption.
But with this radix
idea, we'd like
to see how much better we
can do with d equals 4.
And we want to do substantially
better than 21 drops
or whatever we had back there.
So r is 4.
d is 4-- oh, I'm sorry-- d is 4.
n equals 128.
And what we're going to do is,
the smallest number is 0000.
And in brackets, I'm going write
what the decimal representation
is, because I think that
does give you some intuition.
You get a sense of how this
translates into floors.
And after a while,
if you're going
to tell someone to do
this, you want to give them
floor numbers in decimal.
Because the Shanghai
Tower doesn't
have some weird
representation for the floors
when you get into an elevator
or anything like that.
So this is floor 0.
And now, the highest number is
3333, which happens to be 255.
I'm not going to
write floor each time.
But when I put things
in brackets here,
that's the decimal
representation.
OK.
So that's 255.
So that's obviously too big.
We don't need that.
But we're stuck with
having to choose
r equals 4 for the reasons
I described to you before.
So there's somewhere
in here there's a 128.
And I don't have it
right up in front of me
as to what 128
would correspond to.
But 1233, for example,
would be floor 111.
So the way this
works, and you all
know you're radix
arithmetic, it's
3 times 1, plus 3 times 4, plus
2 times 4 square, plus 1 times
4 cubed.
That's what you have.
And that's how you get 111.
So what you have to do
in order to do this right
is to start with the most
significant digit, which
is the left-most digit.
And that makes sense, because
we want our intervals,
when we have lots of
balls, to be large.
And that as you move
and the balls break,
you're going to start
shifting rightward.
And you're going to be
incrementing different things.
And that's essentially going to
give us give us our algorithm.
And so we'll talk
about-- let me just
give you an example
of an algorithm.
And we'll look at how the
algorithm is implemented.
As I mentioned, it turns
into 10 lines of code,
because all you're
doing is translating
into this representation.
And you're just incrementing
bits of the representation.
And it's interactive.
You can play with it
later today or whenever.
And you can sort of think
of a hardness coefficient
in your head then see
how things work out.
But before we end,
we obviously will
have to do a worst-case
analysis of this algorithm
because that's the whole
point of this exercise.
So in this case, where
do you think I should--
so I don't want to drop,
obviously, at floor 0.
I mean, that's there's
no notion of that.
So where do I drop
at, at the beginning?
The first drop is at,
given what I told you?
You can tell me in
any representation.
Where would I drop
the first ball
if I have four balls
and 128 floors?
I said that I want to start
with something that, obviously,
there's some larger
interval here.
And I want to start
on the left-hand side.
And I want to increment
the leftmost bit, which
is the most significant bit.
So I would start with 1000.
So the first drop is at
1000, which is at floor 64.
That's the first drop.
Now, if in fact this
does not break--
all right, so let's assume
that this does not break.
Then what do I do next?
2000, right?
And this would be 128.
Let's assume that
this breaks here.
All right.
So now, what do I do?
It broke.
I lost a ball.
Now I have three
balls left still.
That's the good news.
And how many-- so what do I
need, where do I need to move?
If I have three
balls left, I need
to be in a representation
that has how many digits?
Three digits.
So I need to move.
I a broke at 2000, so I know
that it's less than 2000.
So I need to go back to this,
because this is the highest
floor.
In general, whenever
things break,
you go back to the highest
floor that you know
that the ball didn't break.
I mean, that's the
canonical strategy
that we've followed all through.
When the ball
breaks, you go back
and say, oh, but I
do know that there
was a highest floor in which
the ball did not break.
And I have to start
with 1 plus that, right?
So what I'm going to do
here is I need to go up
and because it broke,
I need to look at 1001.
The interval that
I need to look at
is 1001, because it's
one more than that.
And all the way to 1333,
which is one less than that.
So and this, you may
feel a little bit better
looking at this in decimal.
I certainly do.
It's 65, 127, which
makes perfect sense.
So far, we've played around with
the balls, the first two balls.
And so we haven't really seen
anything very dramatically
different from the two-ball
case, but more is coming.
Let's say this does not break.
If this does not break,
then what would I do now?
If it does not break--
I'm sorry, my bad, my bad.
I haven't even told you.
I've just talked
about the interval.
And I haven't said what drop
you need to make, right?
So ignore what I said just now.
I think that the next
question is, the ball broke.
So now I have a second ball.
And I want the first
drop of the second ball.
And I want to look at this.
I want to look at this interval.
And it has to be somewhere
inside this interval.
But it's not going to be--
I'm not going to drop this
at this floor, 65 or 1333.
I want to pick something
in between, right?
And so now looking
at this, tell me--
according to what
you know so far--
where you think I should
drop the second ball
for the first time?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: 96.
SRINI DEVADAS: 96.
And how did you get that?
AUDIENCE: Just like
I did the half point.
SRINI DEVADAS: And you put 1100?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SRINI DEVADAS: Perfect.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Evan.
SRINI DEVADAS: Evan.
So Evan says 96.
I guess he thinks in decimal
naturally, like most of us.
But the way you would
code this, by the way,
is by incrementing this digit.
And you'll get 1100.
And in this case, let's
say it does not break.
Then where do you go, Evan?
AUDIENCE: Above floor 96.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah.
After 96, it doesn't break.
What would you do?
AUDIENCE: Then you would
go to what is that?
SRINI DEVADAS: Well, it's-
AUDIENCE: In decimal?
SRINI DEVADAS: No, in
this representation--
whatever is easier for you.
AUDIENCE: It would be 1200.
SRINI DEVADAS:
Perfect, 1200, which
happens to be I think 112.
So you go to floor 112.
This was 96, and then you needed
to add another 16 to that--
yep, 112 and so on.
So I won't bore you with this.
You get a sense of
what's going on here.
And obviously with these
things, you can wave your hands
and you get a sense
of what's going on.
But ultimately, you know, what's
great about computer science
and programming is you've got
to teach a dumb computer to do
exactly the right thing.
And there's no two things
about it in terms of you
understand this algorithm.
I didn't understand
this algorithm
until I coded it, fully.
I mean, maybe I still
don't understand it,
considering the
mistakes I'm making.
But that's just because I've
lost a bunch of gray cells.
So let me show you what
the code looks like.
It's 15 lines of code.
It's not that much.
And as you can imagine,
the representation is--
I could have used many things.
I just used a list for
each of these digits.
I'm incrementing these digits.
And I won't spend a whole
lot of time on the code,
but what I want to do before
we end here is talk about--
actually, let me do that first,
before we go to the code.
I want to talk about
the worst case here,
because that's what
this is all about.
I want to get an equation,
just like we did for 2 times
square root of n minus 1 and
all of these different things, I
want to get an equation
for the worst case in terms
of the number of drops
in relation to r and d,
which are obviously
related to n.
Because r raised to d
has to be greater than n.
So if you kind of look
at this, and it turns
out this is not a
difficult analysis--
if you think about
it, and you start
thinking about
worst case, and you
think about how we're
incrementing these things,
there's phases.
And if you can think about a
phase as when a ball breaks,
you know, that's
when a phase is done.
And you move to
the second phase.
Tell me how many drops I have?
You break it up in terms
of the number of phases
or the number of balls,
whichever way you want
to think about it,
and use the same kind
of worst-case analysis
we've done with respect
to what happens
in the worst case.
You have to keep doing
a bunch of drops.
And really, for these
algorithms, the floor 127,
the hardness coefficient of--
actually, the hardness
coefficient of 127
is the hard one, right?
It's the difficult one,
because you kind of go through
and you go all the way there.
And you do all of these
things before-- you
drop the ball a lot of
times before it breaks.
And you do that for every ball.
That would be the
worst case, right?
So that's kind of
where things are at.
So from a symbolic
standpoint, what
is the worst case
in the first phase
in terms of the number of
drops of the first ball,
from a symbolic standpoint?
It's the first digit
I'm talking about.
It's the first ball
And I'm dropping this
ball, as you can see,
at these different points.
So in general, how many drops
would I have before I'm either,
I may be done completely because
I know it doesn't break a floor
128 or what have you.
But what is the worst case
when that ball breaks?
Give me an equation.
Someone.
So I drop it once.
I drop it twice.
Am I going to drop
it like, if r is 5,
am I going to drop it 10 times?
What am I doing
in terms of the--
what is the upper limit
in terms of this digit?
AUDIENCE: r minus 1.
SRINI DEVADAS: r minus 1.
And where am I starting from?
1, so there you go.
What's the answer?
AUDIENCE: r minus 1.
SRINI DEVADAS: r minus 1, right?
So that's it.
So it turns out that I have
r minus 1 drops in the worst
case for the first ball.
And, I mean, it's the
same representation.
Every digit is the
same radix, obviously.
And now, that ball broke and
I moved to the second digit
with the second ball.
And I'm going to start again.
And in the worst case, I could
have r minus 1 drops for that
as well, right, because I'm
going to go increment from 0.
The first one I'm
going to do is a 1.
And then I'm going to do a 2
and all the way to r minus 1.
So r minus 1 drops
for the second ball.
And then I go all
the way to d balls.
So my answer-- yeah, go ahead.
Over here.
Ganatra.
AUDIENCE: So r is
4 in this case.
And we say the worse case is 3.
But how do we get 3?
Because if it doesn't
break on either of those,
on the 1000 and 2000,
aren't we just done
and that's only two drops?
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah.
So it gets a little--
you're absolutely right.
But if the number were 255--
so one of the things
that's happening here
is we've lost some precision
because r raised to d needed
to be this large number of 255.
And this algorithm is actually
going to work for 255 floors.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's because of n.
SRINI DEVADAS:
Yeah, because of n.
So it's not, yeah, so
that's kind of-- you know,
it's a good question you asked.
But unfortunately,
you kind of want
to choose a case where you
have perfect precision in terms
of r raised to d is exactly
what you need it to be.
And in that case,
this analysis works.
AUDIENCE: So it
works the max end.
SRINI DEVADAS: That's
it, the max end.
That's exactly right.
So I mean, 255 is
substantially larger than 128.
So it kind of makes
sense that, as you said,
that you would be able to
shave off certain things.
And so you can kind
of do that, but it's
a little more involved.
But I think the
intuition is important.
And the intuition is simply
that your worst-case number
of drops, assuming you're
being a little bit imprecise,
would simply be r minus 1
times d in the worst case.
And this would be true for
all n which is less than r
raised to d, for all n.
So now, just in
terms of numbers,
I had r equals 4 and d equals 4.
And so you end up getting 12
drops for the 128 case, all
the way to 255 as well.
You need 12 drops
in the worst case,
even for 255 floors, which is
really what you were asking.
So good.
Right.
That makes sense?
So I'm not going to spend a
whole lot of time on this code,
but that's it.
It's converting.
I could've used a Python
library function for that,
but that's simply a
conversion because I
wanted to print things out.
I don't even need that,
this particular subroutine,
which is essentially
something that
is doing conversion from
decimal to r-ary arithmetic.
And as you can see, you
see I subtract and adding.
The adding this is the
incrementation that I just
erased, but you do see it
up there from 1 0 to 2 0.
That's why you add.
Sometimes you need to
subtract, because things break.
And when things break, you need
to go back to the highest floor
where the ball didn't break.
So that's where you
do the subtraction.
And so this is how,
if you ran this,
it's not the greatest user
interface, I'll admit.
But that's not the point.
The Crystal.
So I'm going to do at 128
and 4, which is our example.
And it says radix
shows it as ball 4.
Did the ball break?
I say no.
And then drop the ball.
Did the ball Break if I
say no here, then I'm done.
So I'm going to go
ahead and say yes.
And then I'm going to
say no and then no.
I'm going to keep going--
no, no, no, no-- because
this is the worst case.
And I go to 11 in this case.
So you do get close in the
sense that Ganatra was asking,
you know, could you shave off?
You only shaved off one
because of the imprecision.
So there is a case where
even though you would only
get 12 for 255, but
you do get 11 for 128.
OK.
Cool.
Good.
So I'll let you
look at the code.
If you guys can leave
any time you want.
I just wanted to
mention, I wanted
to go back to the
one thing that I
didn't get that I mentioned,
but I haven't gotten to do,
which is this is still--
you could still do better.
You can still do better
not because of what Ganatra
mentioned-- you know, that's
just that imprecision thing,
but assuming even
that was taken care
of because the
numbers worked out,
You can do better because
k can be made a different.
You could do unequal intervals.
So let me put that
in the notes and you
can read it by yourself.
You had a question, Evan.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
When you were going
through the ball drops
and you kept answering no,
that the ball did not break,
why did it start asking you or
why did it start telling you
where the next ball dropped?
Because it went
one, two, and then
it went also to ball
three and ball four.
So will it just stay ball
two the whole time it
if never broke?
SRINI DEVADAS:
That's exactly right,
but that's because I'm lazy.
Yeah.
So it'd be a fine
exercise to fix that.
I mean, that's not
one of the exercises.
That's how you turn, you know
after 30 years of teaching
whenever I get a
question, I turn it
into an opportunity
for homework.
OK.
Right.
That's how it works.
All right.
Good.
See you guys next time.